i want to read for you a quote all right
this is a very a very important quote
from a very smart man who said
perhaps law-abiding states should bond
together and form a union of states that
will abide by the constitution
texas gop chairman alan west said in a
statement friday night
the texas gop will always stand for the
constitution and for the rule of law
even while others don't very funny joke
i know it's your quote
but uh you said that and just in the
context of what has been happening
not just and this was in the context of
the election and the supreme court's
ruling yeah against the state of texas
and
the other states coming together about
the unconstitutional actions right right
looking at that looking at the bigger
picture uh uh i think it's fair to say
we are seeing the constitution
be used well i won't be too disrespect
disrespectful myself but let's just say
they are absolutely disrespecting
violating and turning the constitution
into swiss cheese
completely so you had this statement
that many said you are essentially
calling for secession
and it actually sounds like you were
accusing them of secession
you know you know what this is right you
got the declaration of independence
right there
and the constitution yeah see it's
falling apart because you know i you
know i'll take it everywhere i go
so uh let me see let me go to where's
that whole preamble thing
oh there it is so the preamble we the
people of the united states in order to
what form a more perfect union
and in order to form a more perfect
union what's the first thing we do
establish justice
so again coming back to that piece that
i wrote yesterday constitutionalist
versus secessionists
the people that are succeeding or the
people that are violating this
document the people that are
constitutional and law abiding like we
saw in this past election cycle
you have several states where governors
secretaries of state
and courts did unconstitutional actions
the only people that can change election
law
is the legislative branch yes but yet
that's not what we saw happen so
that's not a debatable thing i mean
youtube is not going to cancel you out
unless youtube doesn't understand
the constitution but yet we have people
that allowed that to happen
absolutely and we we had numerous
instances i think 24 states
yes where outside of a legislature
election rules were changed and that's
wrong
some of these states didn't challenge it
many of them did and
somehow none of them got standing
or or ruled on the merits and that's
horrible because if you're a state of
texas and you join with 17 other states
and you are going to constitutional
right
petition your government for redress of
grievance against another state there's
only one court you can go to
the court of original jurisdiction is
the united states supreme court
united states supreme court cannot say
to texas that we're not going to hear
the case
they didn't that's but that's your job
right and so
again we have this abdication of the
rule of law and those constitutional
duties and responsibilities
and for those people that want to say
that you know i'm talking about
succeeding well then what was the
national popular vote interstate compact
all about
where these blue states were going to
come together and undermine the
electoral college
okay which is in the constitution is in
the constitution so they're the real
successions ian you had
yeah i feel like they're using martial
laws like impetus to
to you know buy bypass rights
and and they're they're acting like
covet is such um
an emergency that they have to do this
now you served as lieutenant colonel and
i imagine you understand the the
necessity for martial law in certain
situations if we were under attack
or if something horrible you know yeah
99 yeah worst case scenario power grid
goes out
invasion whatever yeah like martial
lights went out in texas just recently
yeah
people would be and in the past have
been stripped of their constitutional
rights
you know habeas corpus was suspended
abraham lincoln yeah so
but this ain't it this ain't it folks
okay
let's honestly talk about covet we're
talking about something that has a 99.96
recovery rate okay even the cdc came out
last fall and said
that uh out of all the deaths attributed
to covet
only six percent were because of 94
percent were based
basically people that died with covet
they had other co-morbidities
they were obese high blood pressure
heart disease
uh type 2 diabetes all of these things
so
well so i'll push back a little bit okay
and and give my standard clarification
i guess the the only way i can really
break down kind of a middle ground on
this assessment is
these people would have lived longer had
it not been for coveted
so some of these people that have renal
failure and a lot of conservatives have
pointed but how much
longer how i mean how do we know that i
mean some some of these i mean
you look at the preponderance of the
deaths with covet
we're above 70 years of age yes
absolutely okay so
i mean so very strong is that is that
the reason why you
go in and suspend the constitutional
rights
of an entire country well so so here's
the point i want to make
even if it were that kovit was the
the number one cause outside of any
comorbidity the answer is still no
we we we have to respect as a community
when we set certain
we have emergencies but even when you
look at the grand total uh
i think it's 97.5 percent recovery when
you include those over 70
i mean that's still ridiculously high
granted that's
looking at a lot of deaths that you know
2.5 percent out of 330 million is yeah
but
every year you average almost 600 000
with heart disease
right and obesity yes and we do every
year we don't lock down the country we
don't
mandate calisthenics programs no we do
not shut things down because people are
doing things that
can be arguably socially contagious like
bad habits
think about how stupid it is okay so we
know obesity
is one of the things that you know
together with covic causes death but yet
we're going to shut down gems
right yeah i mean keep alcohol and not
only that but
vitamin uh like a vitamin d dr himself
we lock everyone in their houses yeah
stay inside and we know that covid was
spreading more inside than outside
yeah we lock everyone in their homes
with no sun with no exercise
and a higher chance of rate of spreading
covet what did people think was going to
happen
so it was it but but see the the thing
and and again
no emergency is grounds to suspend the
rule of law
so what this was was a grand experiment
in
control what do you think that you think
the civil war was
was grounds for suspending the
constitution abraham lincoln did it
i know but i would not have yeah i mean
you cannot suspend you know people's
habits corpus but
you know the interesting thing is that
you had a
a situation where you know we were
fighting against each other
with within you know the same spaces i
mean you know
here we have you know west virginia and
you know being on one side virginia is
on another side and pennsylvania's on
another side
but still you don't suspend
constitutional rights no matter what and
that goes back to what
franklin delano roosevelt did with the
japanese americans
with internment camps i understand the
criticality of the situation but you do
not suspend
people's constitutional rights agreed
but they have put their toes in the
water
and they found that the water was very
receiving
yeah and so what is the next step well
have you heard of this
the great reset the world economic forum
i mean i think that the u.s has been
co-opted by the federal reserve and
global banking establishments and
they're using our military and our
economy and where do you find the
premise of central banking
switzerland and the bank of
international settlements call mark's
communist manifesto
is that really in there it is
centralized control of banks just like
centralized control of education just
like progressive tax system
you know we have a tax system in the
united states of america that's based
upon the principles of karl marx
a progressive tax system and so again
there's so much of this out there that
if a dumb old boy from georgia who used
to jump out of airplanes for a living if
i can figure this out
you really smart people can figure this
out well let's
yeah i couldn't fly airplanes i jumped
out oh wow so let's have a conversation
on this because
uh there are a lot of things that are
more liberal or left-wing policies that
i agree with
but my challenge one of the things that
always leaves me more of a moderate in
the middle is
implementation so when i look at the
progressive tax
i think about people like george soros i
think about the koch brothers i think
about
uh did i say bezos i said soros bezos
extremely powerful individuals who have
so much wealth they've actually shut out
the working classroom election process
so i'll give you some examples
mike bloomberg dumping 500 600 million
dollars into the election
oh we saw that with mark zuckerberg 300
yeah into texas to directly to
a a uh a county clerk's office so no we
we should not allow that to happen
so a few years ago i was very much i i
should say for a long
a large portion of my life i was very
much in favor of a progressive tax
system where we have a higher percentage
for people who make more
because of i guess arguably called the
law of power right power attracts power
the more money you make the easier it is
for you to make more money
and this money allows you to invest
reduce risk
live comfortably if you make 10 million
dollars it's very very easy for you to
make more because you have so much
access
and things like that so i would disagree
with you
disagree yes how is it that a kid
that doesn't even have a college
education can grow up and be a
multi-millionaire in the united states
of america
they can yeah and so it's about the
quality of opportunity i i what you're
talking about is the corruption of power
and and and so what it takes i mean much
the same as sir edmund burke said
all is necessary uh for to triumph over
evil is for good men to do nothing
so if we continue to have a political
elite system
which i think even amran kind of wrote
about if we have a political elite
system that teams up with the
the corporate cronies and the elites of
corporations like what we see with big
tech right now
then you see a user patient so my view
of the progressive tax was
it in a simplistic kind of way you can
create a system makes it harder for
people with extreme wealth
to utilize that wealth as an advantage
over the working class in the arena of
politics that's my core reason
and and i agree with you that like i
said it's the corruption of power
here's the problem giving the money to
the government doesn't solve the problem
because now you have another monopoly
that has
all of that power and so you've got
permanent bureaucrats
that would take that money from the
ultra wealthy and then just
maintain their control so you know
ultimately while i still kind of view
that as
a better alternative simply because
there's up
many bureaucrats versus the one
billionaire who can flood the zone with
money and shut out the working class
i i ultimately still see it as a problem
that needs to be solved beyond we don't
allow them to flood the zone
exactly so that's the other point i
would make is maybe the solution is more
simply
some kind of restriction somehow i
honestly don't know how you do it
well this is this is where i think this
is where i think it starts is
you know one of the things that mark
levine wrote about in his book liberty
amendments is term limits
on members of congress house and senate
because the longer people are up here in
washington dc the richer they get
i mean ask yourself how could a young
lady from
brooklyn new york there was a bartender
have a posh
penthouse apartment in washington dc and
you know who i'm talking about yeah
isn't it like three grand a month or
something more a lot okay it's a lot and
so
you know when i was in congress ten
years ago i had a
you know you know fully furnished little
basement little
i called it the bat cave didn't even
have a window they're members of
congress sleeping in their offices
yeah it's a big problem so how does it
and i disagree with that
uh so how is it that you know this
person that was a former bartender now
has a
posh penthouse apartment over there by
washington nationals park
i'm telling you it's this and so is that
is that marrying of the the corporate
cronyism to the political elitism that's
what we all should come together how do
we
i agree you know i hear it from the
progressives i hear from the young turks
and i completely agree with them
the problem is you know like the
citizens united ruling which i'm sure
you're familiar with
you know you've got these super pacs
these political action committees
how do you tell someone they can't spend
their money to buy a commercial i mean
it's a free speech
i don't i don't mind people about you
know buying the money for a commercial i
don't want them buying a politician
well how do they do that you make sure
that they cannot buy a politician you
pass the laws like what we're doing in
texas right now in our legislative
session
that says margaret zuckerberg you don't
get to come back in here and dump a
hundred thousand dollars
in harris county so that they can go out
and number one try to do universal mail
and ballots which is against texas
election law
and they expand curbside voting which is
completely against
against texas election law so that's
what you do
our states have power that's why you
have a 10th amendment
it says all the powers not delegated to
the federal government are reserved to
the states and to the people so our
states
need to assert their powers and make
sure that like i said coming back to hr1
and some of these other things to be in
past
constitutional nullification was pretty
much so passed in north dakota well
let's talk about hr one yeah right so
it passed the house passed the house
it's not yet gone to the senate right
well it's over to the senate but the
thing is right now this is the concern
right now the senate still
you have to have 60 votes to end the
cloture which means that you can go into
the final
vote if they change that and get rid of
the filibuster then you got problems
yeah now what keeps the democrats right
now from going straight to uh getting
rid of filibuster joe manchin and
kirsten sinema
west virginia and arizona have said they
will not support getting rid of the
filibuster
so we'll see what happens but they can
just all of a sudden snap their fingers
and be like yeah no more filibusters and
now it's allowed
no that would be 51 votes or 50 votes in
a tiebreaker
and the tiebreaker's kamala harris and
see that's why the senate was set up to
be
the upper body of our legislation
legislative branch
and it will require 60 votes because
what the founding fathers wanted to make
sure sure you got the representation of
the people that's majority
but over here in the senate that's the
clearinghouse so everything can't
just get rammed right through you really
have to have a deliberative body
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time